thank you thank you ladies and gentlemen
thank you thank you overwhelmed and
welcome to this week's episode of I
don't even know where to start
that's what I'm renaming this show I
well I'm sure you've seen the news Trump
has two new best friends Rudy Giuliani
and Kanye West its psyche he joined a
new dating site
okay stupid
so rudy guiliani as you know replaces
michael cohen that was his lawyer so
Rudy's in for michael cohen he's traded
a lawyer who carries a bat for a lawyer
it turns into one and Rudy had a pretty
rough beginning I did it seems like
weeks ago it was only yesterday the lies
turn over so quickly Rudy was all over
fox news admitted that Trump fired call
me because of the Russian investigation
admitted that Trump reimbursed Cohen for
the store McDaniels pay up admitted that
Trump knew about the hush money to
stormy Daniels I think the person who
needs money to hush is Rudy it's a
brilliant legal strategy called
confessing so according to Rudy here's
what we're supposed to believe the Trump
has a default arrangement with his
lawyer that if any porn star anywhere in
America that I banged at a golf club
says she did you don't have to check
with me just pay so Trump sees this on
TV of course what he does all day
watching just sees what he say this on
Fox and tweets you know that hush money
that I don't know anything about yeah
that came from my personal completely
normal automated porn star pay off slush
fund just like we all have
what the fuss is about what is the
present back it's simply a donation to
store me for some charity work she did
on my penis that these guys it's like
improv comedy except it's not funny so
it's just like improv comedy No
so today of course both of them clearly
reversed everything that was said
yesterday virtually everything that was
a Trudy said that he had been said
incorrectly it's been what the [ __ ] am I
trying to say they've got me tongue-tied
Trump said that everything Rudy said was
said incorrectly and has been said wrong
and that Sarah Huckabee Sanders job you
know hit rock bottom when Trump is
cleaning up your quotes
well that's not what Rudy meant to say
here to explain is the monkey from
rampage so lost in this incestuous fox
news loop you know they don't even know
who's talking to who because of what
it's like did I send you out on Fox to
talk to me or did I go on there to fool
the American people broody and Trump
first of all they're both senile they're
both [ __ ] some guys you got to write
your lies down
you know how it is at that age
[Music]
so let's you walk into a room and you
forget what lie you came in there for
you know it's
but Trump has it under control he told
reporters today that the FBI should
really be going after a someone named
Hillary Clinton
apparently she hid 30,000 emails oh [ __ ]
its 2018 she lost shut up about the damn
emails he's like a parrot playing a
drinking game on Groundhog Day this was
any other presidents heed this what I'm
about to tell you would have been a
giant scandal
apparently Trump raided his own doctor's
office to steal his own medical records
do you know this he's got this doctor
for 35 years dr. Vinny boombots no
doctor dr. Harold berry is dr. Harold
born sane wouldn't you want to go too
for him to get a prostate exam they
raided his office and I love this part
rated as novice took the medical records
in Trump's portrait was hanging on the
wall in the waiting room ripped that off
the wall first of all if you're going to
a doctor who has headshots in the
waiting room that's not a doctor that's
a dry cleaner but but just when you
think Trump can't be more thin-skinned
apparently the reason for this raid on
his doctor's office is that he was so
mad at his doctor for revealing to the
media the Trump takes propecia you know
the hair drug Trump shouldn't be
embarrassed that he takes propecia
propecia should be embarrassed if
they're responsible for Trump's
[Applause]